قال رئيس الوزراء السويدي الفا كريستوستون
قال ان التركيه طلبتها اشياء لا يمكن
تلبيتها للموافقه على انضمام السويد
بالمقابل ثقه بلاده من ان تركيا ستوافق
على طلب انضمام السويد للنيتو
تركيا
[موسيقى]
واقال انه حان الوقت لنهائي ذلك بالنظر
الالتزام الدولتين بالتعاون مع الجانب
التركي
بوضوح بالتعاون طويل الامد مع تركيا في
القضايا التي بين الجانبين لذلك حان الوقت
للانتهاء من عمليه الانضمام والتصديق على
بروتوكول الانضمام
ليه مناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم لنا من دي
متروس
في معهد الدفاع الوطني السويدي ومن انقره
مراد اصلان الخبير الاستراتيجي والمحلل
السياسي في مركز سيتا للابحاث ونبدا اولا
مع ستكون والسيد ديميترس سند متروس ما هي
المطالب التركيه التي لا تستطيع السويد
تنفيذ
سباق
مع
الصحفي الذي رفض الترحيل وتركيا اراده قبل
اسابيع ان يتم ترحيله
وايضا كذلك
قرار المحكمه العليا
على اساس انه عضو في حركه
كما قلته في محاوله الانقلاب
الفاشله التي تمت في العام
2016 بالنسبه للمحكمه التفسير الذي قدمته
ان العضويه في حركه ظلال ليس جريمه في
السويد
والنقطه الاخرى التي
اتذكرت عن ضلوعه
في
العمليات الانقلاب الفاشل هي ايضا نقطه لا
يمكن ان تقبلها المحكمه لانه في حاله تم
ترحيبه فانه سيواجهه
مخاطر جمع على حياته قد يتعرض للتعذيب او
السجن اذا هذا سيتنافى مع القانون السوري
هذا السبب همم
سواء كان الامر متعلقه
رئيس الوزراء
الذي تحدث اليوم رئيس الوزراء الماضي لا
يمكنه ما ان يتصرفات هكذا من تلقائي نفسه
لان النظام هناك نظام نور
ده متر سيد مراد عثمان استمعت ويتحدث عن
اجراء قانوني في بلاده لا يمكن تجاوز هذا
الاجراء برامج
تركيا في بالنسبه لعضويه
اولا التضامن في مجال مكافحه الارهاب
والثانيا
الرفعه همم حظر على الاسلحه
همم تركيا القضيه الثانيه حلت لكن القضيه
الاولى بقيت صعبه نحن نعرف ان السويد بلد
جميل ورائع وسعيد ولكن هذا لا يعني
بالضروره تركيا
ستقبل كل شيء يطرح من جانبها الله لان
هناك شيء يحصل داخل الاراضي تركيا والذي
يهدد الحياه المدنيه
الصحافه ليست عذرا في عدم عدم تسليم
الارهابين لان الارهاب ليس عاده مهنه يعلن
عنها بل الصحافه تستخدم كذريعه وكاغطاء
ايضا في حاله ايضا الاتهام بعضويه منظمه
لماذا لا يرسلون الشخص الى تركيا وتنظر
المحكمه التركيه
عن اجراءات قانونيه قال لا يمكن تجاوزها
وابقى معك سيد مراد اصلان الامين العام في
شمال
قال حان الوقت لانهاء هذا الموضوع او
الخلاف حول انضمام السويد بالنظر الالتزام
الدولتين وايضا فنلندا بالتعاون مع الجانب
التركي يعني هذا شاهد كبير على التزام
الدوله
nh2
تماما فهو يتحدث عن التزام تجاه دوله
السويد وهذا امر تفهمه تركيا لكن المشكله
اذا انك فقط تتماها معهم فورا تركيا وبقيت
طالب الانضمام لمده 60 عاما وما زالت
مرشحه اذا لماذا لا تبقى السويد مرشحه فقط
ل 60 عاما اخرى ما لم
ينفذ ما ما ما وقعوا عليه حرفيا وعمليا
ما دلاله تصريح رئيس الوزراء السويدي بهذا
الموقف بشكل علني يعني قال بالنهايه يعني
تركيا ستوافق وتاكده ان تركيا لم ترفض
انضمام السويد ل ل لنيته مثلا ذلك ابراهيم
السويدي والمسؤولون
السويديون حتى وزير الخارجيهم
يتظاهرون بان كل شيء تم عمله كل ما كان
ينبغي عمله قد تم انجازه للانضمام الى حلف
النيته من وجهه نظرهم لكن كما قلته اعتقد
ان لدي شعور بانهم يتظاهرون في ذلك لانهم
انتهوا عليهم ان يقنع الراي العام في
الداخل ولا انه هناك قضايا في غايه
الحساسيه والاهم من ذلك
النظام
العداله في السويد
كمال طالب الضيف من انقره فان المحكمه
التركيه ستقرر هل هو باريس
للسيد مراد اصلان في في ختام هذا اللقاء
تفضل يا مراد
مراد اصلان اعطيك حق الرد تفضل
اوبجي
القانون التركي القانون التركي
السويديه هم في هذه الحاله يتحدون
من تركيا
دي بتريوس اا
كاركمانيسا الباحثه همم السابق في معهد
الدفاع الوطني السويدي كان معنا مسقطبل